le césar de la meilleure actrice est
attribué alors qu'elle a mené dans
antoinette dans les cévennes incarne une
institutrice qui décide de rejoindre sur
le prévenir son amant qui a annulé au
dernier moment leur semaine d'un bureau
pour partir en randonnée dans les
cévennes avec sa femme et leur fille une
randonnée de 7 néophyte dans ce domaine
sera elle avec son compagnon own and
head avait patrick elle avait été nommée
on second rôle pour avant 2018 de se les
mettre en 2020 le grand public la
connaît évidemment pour son rôle dans la
série 10%
et moi à ces têtes au scope on n'entend
rien le début d'un décès je sais pas
voilà je suis parent dont il faut que je
connais c'est votre moment alors déjà
merci à toutes et à tous ah la la merde
merci caroline ses larges que le doigt
parce qu'il ya les actrices et puis il
ya les rôles et celui-là il était
gigantesque
donc voilà j'admire ton talent rare ta
ténacité notre amour du pathétique drôle
et voilà j'espère vraiment que je
pourrais encore jouer de t notes
espiègle voilà merci beaucoup
le jeu c'est l'autre donc évidemment ce
césar je veux partager avec tous mes
partenaires batwa benjamin en premier
que là ce soir
la classe folle même dans une buanderie
et olivia cote et marées rivières marc
fraises jean pierre denis enfin toute la
troupe parce que c'était comme une
troupe de théâtre dans nos gîtes à
florac toute l'équipe technique
les productrices laetitia galitzine
rillieux robière diaphana voilà ça c'est
pour la partie humaine se tient à
remercier aussi mon partenaire animalier
voilà qui doit à brouter dans son pré
tranquille avec des draw et qu'ils s'en
foutent tout ça et puis je tenais aussi
à remercier
non mes amis lena thomas jean françois
nicolas ceux qui sont sains et en fait
je voulais vous est chère à mon coeur et
sans bouger je serai pas dans le choses
et je voulais aussi remercier mon ami
paul emploi qui m'a soutenu pendant
toutes ces années
du moins quand je pouvais lui ramener
suffisamment d'heures et voilà sans ton
existence beaucoup de projets que j'ai
fais tu le sais vincent n'aurait pas
forcément vu le jour car c'est une
subvention en fait un direct aux
artistes pour le leur spectacle d'une
certaine façon et me voilà et je voulais
pardon je voulais enfin je repense à la
jeune provincial que j'étais et je
repense au centre dramatique national
d'orléans et au cinéma les carmes qui
s'appelait autrefois le mar 3 où j'ai eu
mes premières émotions ce festival frank
capra où j'ai découvert la vie est belle
ou james stewart désespéré veut se
suicider et d'un coup un ange un peu
foireux de seconde classe va essayer de
lui redonner le goût à la vie en lui
montrant ce qu aurait été la vie de sa
ville et de ses proches s'il n'avait pas
existé
et comme c'était plutôt un homme qui
faisait beaucoup de choses pour les
autres voilà le tableau était terrible
sans son existence et je pense du coup
ce qu'on appelait des fous au sortir de
la seconde guerre mondiale qui ont
décidé de créer la décentralisation de
créer des théâtres dans les provinces
pour que l'accès à l'art ne soit pas
uniquement parisien et sens tous et
james stewart là la jeune provincial que
j' étais aurait eu une vie beaucoup plus
sinistre voilà donc laissez nous
laissez-nous assouvir notre soif de sens
ou de non sens laissez-nous exulter
devant les oeuvres d'art
laissez-nous nous exiler dans nos
imaginaires
laissez nous entendre ce qui fait de
nous des êtres humains
voilà je dédie juste avant de partir
ce césar à mon amoureux des montagnes et
pour le coup ça c'est pas essentiel mais
ça fait vachement plaisir merci bravo
avant merci la bravo à léry merci au
revoir